ja wir kommen zur aktuellen vorlesung in
der es um die ästhetik der digitalität
geht den ersten teil dieser
thematik und zwar heute um virtuelle
kunst wie immer gibt es zu beginn ein
rückblick auf die letzte sitzung der wir
uns mit der ethik des virtuellen
handlungsrahmens beschäftigt haben dann
komme auf das eigentliche thema der
heutigen vorlesung zu sprechen virtuelle
kunst und am schluss gibt es einen
ausblick auf die nächste vorlesung die
ebenfalls der ästhetik der digitalität
gewidmet ist diesmal aber ganz speziell
dem phänomen der computerspiele ja was
ist ethik der digitalität
der digitalität muss auf die virtuelle
realität der digitalität reflektieren
wir hatten ausführlich in einer
vorlesung thema virtuelle realität
behandelt ich nach oben rechts und links
und diese etr digitalität wo sich opfern
bloß instrumentellen zugang zur
digitalisierung abgrenzen das bedeutet
digitalisierung ist nicht nur ein
hilfsmittel in uns im alltag das wäre zu
schwach weil virtuelle realität mehr ist
als nur ein hilfsmittel virtuelle
realität ist eine erweiterung unserer
realität in diesem sinne der erweiterung
unserer realität verstehe ich die
vitalität durch digitalisierung
ein weiterer punkt der die elite
digitalität betrifft ist das eine solche
ethik zunächst stimmen muss was eine
virtuelle handlung und was ein
virtueller akteur eine virtuelle
akteuren ist das sind die bestandteile
die grundlagen auf denen dann erst eine
ethik der digitalität beginnen kann wenn
sie schon mal mit handlungen
handlungsräume und auch virtuellen
akteuren zurechtkommt begrifflich dann
ist es ganz wichtig das internet als
einen virtuellen handlungsraum zu
erkennen und nicht nur als ein medium
des informationsaustausches wir haben
gesehen einer statistik dass das
internet immer noch sehr häufig nur zum
senden empfangen
informationen e mails genutzt wird das
wäre natürlich zu wenig um das internet
als einen handlungsraum zu bestimmen
auch wenn das versenden oder das
austauschen von information natürlich
auch die handlung ist aber das ist eine
handlung die noch sehr schwachen ist
niederschwellig und die nicht das ganze
virtuelle potenzial des internets als
einen virtuellen handlungsraum
ausschöpft da gibt es also noch ganz
andere dinge wir sehen durch die korona
krise dass
meetings oder auch videos jetzt erleben
hier gerade online
leere online vorlesung dass die immer
mehr ins zentrum rücken und virtuelle
lehre als ebenbild zur traditionellen
physisch gebundenen lehrern angesehen
sind es gibt auch mischformen hybride
leere das alles sind neue entwickler das
heißt die welt der digitalität muss auch
ethische regeln formulieren die vor
allen virtuellen akteure eine virtuelle
akteure im virtuellen handlungsraum
gelten hier stellt sich die frage können
wir diese regeln diese ethischen regeln
die gebote die gesetze analog
formulieren zum physischen
traditionellen handlungsraum oder müssen
sie modifiziert werden aufgrund der
anderen raum und zeit logik des
virtuellen handlungsraum ich glaube dass
das letzte mal ist dass sie modifiziert
werden müssen und dass hier sind gerade
die besondere herausforderung der
philosophie der digitalität besteht
weiter muss eine ewige digitalität neben
digitalen rechten das betrifft jetzt vor
allem auch die politik der digitalität
neben digitalen rechten ich hatte
verwiesen auf die charta der
digitalen richtig macht auch oben rechts
ein link zu dieser sitzung der letzten
hinein außer diesen digitalen rechten
tauchen wir wie ich finde auch ein
katalog digitaler pflichten kein recht
ohne pflicht wie kann jetzt eine
digitale pflicht aussehen
sie kann vielleicht darin bestehen dass
wir
medienkompetenz entwickeln
spezifisch digitale tugenden ausbilden
und hier uns dann wieder fragen wie ich
es ethische paradigma trugen tätig die
ontologie oder konsequenz allis muss für
den virtuellen handlungsraum des
internets zum beispiel am besten gelten
kann und dadurch eine normativ zu
bestimmen auch abzugrenzen
medienkompetenz darauf jedenfalls nicht
rein technologisch verstanden werden in
dem sinne dass ich mir irgendwie eine
digitale balance vornehme nicht so
häufig vor dem computer zu sitzen das
wäre ein viel zu schwach es verständnis
von medienkompetenz
medienkompetenz muss stärker verstanden
werden als eine virtuelle
lebensweltliche tugend im
verhandlungsraum also wie verhalte ich
mich wie orientiere ich mich im
virtuellen glücksrad und nicht nur wie
viel digitalisierung möchte ich in
meinen alltag einbeziehung glaube diese
frage wird gar nicht mehr in der zukunft
zu diskutieren sein es wird einfach
faktisch sein dass die digitalität dass
die digitalisierung unseren alltag
durchdringt und die frage ist nur wie
gehen wir damit um und mein argument
wird sein müssen so damit umgehen dass
wir die digitalisierung als ein
lebensweltlichen faktor verstehen und
dass wir sie so einsetzende digitale
technik dass sie zur erweiterung unserer
bisherigen realität der physisch
gebunden zu einer virtuellen realität
beitragen können dass die digitale
tugend bedeutet den übergang von der
digitalisierung verstanden als war ein
technisches technologisches phänomen zur
digitalität zu vollziehen in diesem
sinne ist der begriff der digitalität
bereits schwach normativ alle auf einem
tollen zustand verweist nämlich diese
lebensweltlich integration
und damit verweist der bereits auf eine
ethik der digitalität
das möchte ich noch mal kurz auf einen
ausblick zu sprechen kommen nämlich das
digitale gute böse
das kann man sich jetzt natürlich fragen
wenn man eine ledige digitalität
formuliert wie sieht denn das digitale
gute böse und digital gut ist in meinen
augen dasjenige was den virtuellen
handlungsraum vergrößert das heißt dass
unsere virtuelle freiheit stärkt was
überhaupt mehr virtuelle realität
schafft virtuelle realität immer auch
verstanden im sinne der vernetzung der
virtuelle handlungsraum des internets
ist kein losgelöster abend sondern seine
räumliche logik besteht gerade darin
immer wieder vernetzungen herzustellen
beispiel für das digitale gute open
access ist also nun kommerzielle
produkte virtuelle produkte zur
verfügung zu stellen freeware globale
bildungsangebote wikipedia ist sie an
erster stelle zu nennen aber natürlich
auch youtube was so verwendet werden
kann barrierefreiheit ratlosigkeit
learning zum beispiel dann aber auch
grenzen kultur beschreiten die
kooperation die das internet ja gerade
ermöglicht und das weiterspielen am
öffentlichen internet ich sage deswegen
öffentlich im netz weil es natürlich
auch noch ein gegen netz gibt das
zeichnet das ich mit dem bösen
tendenziellen verbindung bringen würde
das wäre nämlich ein netz was nicht
abkapselt was den virtuellen
handlungsraum dadurch einschränkt
weiter zählen dazu die reduktion des
virtuellen subjekts zur bloßen
kommerziell verwertbaren metadaten fehlt
der datenschutz abkapselung habe ich
schon gesagt
identitätsdiebstahl schwächung der
internet infrastruktur und des
vertrauens in peking pishing zensur
domain schwierig kate moss und zu
erweitern zu fordern
luciano florida hat in seinem sehr
lesenswerten buch gfx of information
sich auch mit dem aber die fischer
befasst und er geht so weit dass er sagt
wir brauchen eine dritte kategorie des
bösen neben den traditionellen
kategorien des mahnung physikum also des
körperlichen physischen natürlichen
bösen und des meinung moral des bösen
was von menschen verantwortlich
hervorgebracht werden
die frage ist gibt es so ein drittes bis
das auch künstliche agenten tun können
wie ipods und so weiter und so fort das
ist hier eine frage die man noch sehr
sehr trefflich diskutieren kann
jetzt komme ich aber zum eigentlichen
thema der heutigen sitzung nämlich der
ästhetik der digitalität und heute
möchte ich nur zwei phänomene behandeln
nämlich nfc ist nun verstärken und die
ästhetik künstliche intelligenz zum
ersten punkt kann man sagen ganz
generell wenn die digitalisierung einen
virtuellen handlungsrahmen öffnet dafür
habe ich in anderen vorlesungen und auch
heute vorhin stand argumentiert dann
eröffnet sie damit auch einen virtuellen
raum für kunst also kunst virtuelle
kunst aber auch noch traditionelle
physisch gebundene kunstvoll zieht sich
immer in einem raum
virtuelle kunst nicht auf die technik
der digitalisierung die software und die
hardware reduzierbar oder dem tod ohne
an bedeutung zu verlieren
das ist genauso mit der physischen
konsolen physisches nicht digital ist
virtuelles gemälde von picasso ist mehr
als nur farbe auf leinwand
man könnte jetzt sagen das gemälde was
da fünf millionen euro kostet von
picasso das ist doch eigentlich nur
leinwand fasern alte fasern alte
holzplatten und altes öl was ich auf
dieser leinwand befindet und das soll
fünf millionen wert sein das haben wird
das nehme ich ja nicht mal geschenkt
hier besteht darin dass kunst nicht auf
die materielle basis zu reduzieren ist
und genauso wenig scheint mehr virtuelle
kunst reduziert worden seien auf die
digitale technik die analogie wäre die
technik verhält sich wie die leinwand im
traditionellen kunst jahr
allerdings gehorcht virtuelle kunst
einer anderen raumzeit logik als
physische kunst eben weil sie in einem
virtuellen raum erfolgt jetzt wenden wir
uns mal die 94 millionen zu das ist ein
ganz neuartiges versehen darunter ist zu
verstehen ein nicht austauschbares das
heißt individuell ist und einmaliges
digitales unikat
dieses unikat dieses digitalen oder
virtuelle unikat lässt sich in analogie
zu einem physischen unikat verstehen
picassos gemälde sind alle unikat es
gibt natürlich auch künstlerin künstler
die gerade weg von diesem unikat wollen
die wollen serielle kunst reproduzierbar
kunst es steht außer frage aber der
kunst wert bemisst sich meistens daran
dass es nur eines gibt davon
ist einmalig ist jetzt ist dieses
problem der individualisierung oder
einmaligkeit in der sphäre der
digitalität eigentlich problematisch
weil er durch die technik der
digitalisierung alles beliebig
vervielfältigt werden kann und so was
wie individualisierung gar nicht mehr
möglich und ich kann eins zu eins kopie
desselben datei machen und sie beliebig
häufig vervielfältiger also eigentlich
hat die digitalität in die
digitalisierung die tendenz die karte zu
vermeiden was ja auch mit vielen
vorteilen hergehen jetzt ist aber gerade
das lft so strukturiert dass es wohl es
im virtuellen digitalen trauen sich
ereignet ein unikat weiterhin ist hier
gibt es ein beispiel hier sieht man ein
bild wenn man genau hinschaut sieht man
es zusammengesetzt aus ganz zwischen
kleineren digitalen bildern im februar
2021 versteigerte christie's das anfangs
nur talken every day is the first
days des us amerikanischen digital
künstlers mike winkelmann das bild ist
eine collage aus 5000 kleinen digitalen
bildern und wurde für
42.000
also 42 millionen
etat also die einer digitalen währung
gegen wird vom volk von 69,3 millionen
us-dollar versteigert
also sind 42.300
29,45 drei täter die entsprechend fast
70 millionen us dollar da die
informationen habe ich aus wikipedia das
kann zu einem weiteren
mft und zwar ein
bild
ob es ein mrt ist muss man auch genau
das suchen es ist jetzt einfach mal ein
bild
ein gemälde das von einer künstlichen
intelligenz hergestellt wurde und zwar
heißt es das porträt topmodel bel ami
und
auch das hat eine rasante interessante
geschichte ist wurde am 25 oktober 2018
ebenfalls vom auktionshaus christie's
für
1500 us-dollar versteigert als eine hohe
summe und das bild wurde eben mit diesem
algorithmus dann auch unten rechts in
diesem gemälde sieht erstellt
der algorithmus war ganz komplex
strukturiert er bestand nämlich aus zwei
komponenten einen generator einen
diskriminiert das system wurde mit
15.000 porträts historischen gemälden
aus einen zeitraum von 14 bis zum
zwanzigsten jahrhundert gefüttert also
eine gewaltige datenbasis und der
generator dieser künstlichen intelligenz
der hatte immer wieder varianten erzeugt
aus basis dieser datengrundlage und der
diskriminierung
versuchen ein unterschied zwischen einem
von menschen gemalten porträt und einem
künstlich erzeugten zu finden sobald der
diskriminiert vor kein unterschied mehr
fand war dieses bild entstanden also der
generator hat eine ganze variante welche
serie von neun
bildern erzeugt die eben immer wieder
teile oder momente dieser 15.000
porträts transformiert
aufgenommen hatte und wenn der
diskriminiert der auffassung aus
anschluss zeigen war dass das ein
menschen gemaltes porträt also eines
dieser 15.000 porträts sein können dann
war damit an gezeigt dass hier eine
gewisse menschliche
leistung zumindest simuliert worden sei
das besondere an dem porträt ist dass es
von der menschlichen vorstellungen eines
porträts aus dem 18 jahrhundert abweicht
obwohl es ziemlich ähnlich sieht es hat
etwas zeitgenössisches an sich und
erinnert den bildern von graeme brown
kunsthistorischen aneignungen und zwar
so sehen diese elefanten aus das ist
auch etwas klassisches aber zugleich ein
verfremdetes moment und so zieht auch
dieses board of montana midas von
künstlicher intelligenz erzeugt wurde
ein weiteres projekt das durch künste
intelligenz ästhetisch erzeugt wurde ist
das beethoven ex de projekt was versteht
sich was versteht man darunter
beethoven hat bekanntermaßen seine
zehnte sinfonie nicht vollendet und
diese künstliche intelligenz dieses
projekt hat sich zum ziel gesetzt sie
anhand von vorhandenen skizzen 40
skizzen aus dem nachlass zu
rekonstruieren ein team von experten für
maschinelles lernen und
musikwissenschaften nutzte diese skizzen
meine cani zu entwickeln die das
vollenden sollte was beethoven
altersgemäß weil er eben 1827 starb
nicht gelang die herausforderung bestand
vor allem darin dass die carrer ein
musikalisches thema beim mehrere taktik
beibehalten und sogar weiterentwickeln
variieren konnte sie kennen das von
vorschlägen wenn sie am smartphone eine
nachricht schreiben und dann
automatische vervollständigung option
angeboten bekommen ich gehe in die
und kommt schule dann können sie durch
künsten intelligenz eine gewisse linie
ziehen gewissen bogen schlagen der
vervollständigung von anfänglichen motiv
und skizzen leben aber dieser bogen der
durch carli geschlagen wird der ist
recht kurz also große motivische
entfaltungen lassen sich nicht oder nur
sehr schwer durch künsten weekends
erzeugen über viele takte in berlin das
war ein problem dass eine melodie nicht
lang mit einem langen atem entwickelt
werden konnte deswegen wurde jetzt um
die ki zunächst mal wieder junge
beethoven trainiert also im kontext
sieht man sich des 18 jahrhunderts und
dann in einem zweiten schritt wurde sie
aus beethovens eigenes werk intoniert
das heißt die calli hat seine art von
bildungsgang genommen die an der
biografie der künstlerischen biografie
ideengeschichtlichen situation von
beethoven orientiert war zuerst wurde
dann eine generelle melodie produziert
mit unterstützung von menschlicher
assistenz die eben diesen bogen schlagen
konnte die motivik den vorhalt eines
motivs und dann wurde von einer anderen
komponente gewissermaßen vertikal dazu
eine harmonisierung und orchestrierung
der horizontal verlaufende melodie
unternehmen also auch hier wie im fall
dieses porträts wo man zwischen
generator diskriminiert tor innerhalb
der kalli unterschied wurde hier auch
intern noch differenziert
so sieht jetzt das cover dieser
dieses projekts aus dieser dass in
familien ich möchte ihnen einen ganz
kurzen
akustischen eindruck vermitteln und
spiele dazu mal ein teil aus dem dritten
satz diese sind von nie ab
[Musik]
ja das soll vom ersten eindruck genügen
wie er sich dafür noch nie interessiert
findet die internet auf youtube immer
danach google noch viel weitere musik
beispiele die man sich anhören kann
es möchte ich noch ein bisschen mehr auf
die frage nach kunst und künstliche
intelligenz eingehen hier gibt es ein
interessantes buch götzen dem warum
kunst und künstliche intelligenz was
recht neu ist dann möchte ich etwas
zitieren aus einem aufsatz darin wie
auch immer die zukunft der maschinen
kreativität interessante interessante
bezeichnung maschine kreativität
aussehen wird die besten fall trägt in
ihre entwicklung und reflexion dazu bei
dass wir die
soziokulturellen auffassungen praktiken
von kunst und kreativität im licht
dieser technologischen veränderungen
überprüfen können
festzustellen bleibt dass der
gesellschaftliche gebrauch von konzepten
der kunst und kreativität soweit diese
sich auf menschen beziehen durch eine
auffallende paradoxie bestimmt ist die
auch in die aktuellen debatten hinein
rat einerseits werden sie derart
inflationär verwendet das unter der
sonne im grunde alles als kreative kunst
gelten kann
während andere sein sonst entsteht
entsprechend die artefakte und
aktivitäten zur mystifizierung und
esoterisch zu verklären insofern sollten
die gegenwärtigen diskussion über
computer kreativität auch dazu
herausfordern ihre lichte die
widersprüche menschliche kreativität und
kunst produktion ernst zu nehmen und
beispielsweise zu hinterfragen wie
machine ähnlich beziehungsweise wie
zwischenmenschlichen und
nichtmenschlichen akzenten verteilt die
geschichte um meiner kreativität kunst
gerade in der industriellen
postindustriellen gesellschaft immer
schon gewesen ist ganz interessant finde
ich hier jetzt den begriff der maschinen
kreativität und da möchte ich jetzt ein
bisschen weiter da anknüpfen
in diesem buch wird auf ein aktuelles
kunstprojekt hingewiesen der künstler
der künstler wie roman lipsky nutzt
längst ein ki system das mit
maschinellen lernens man arbeitet als
muse er füttert ist mit seinen eigenen
bildern damit die maschine im vorschläge
unterbreitet wie sein nächstes werk
aussehen könnte und so sieht jetzt eines
dieser kunstwerke aus was mit hilfe von
ki variiert wurde
lipsky
das stellt jetzt allgemein die frage
nach dem verhältnis von kunst und
künstliche intelligenz
ich bin der meinung dass mensch maschine
interaktion auch unter ästhetischen
gesichtspunkten betrachtet werden kann
wir haben diese menschen maschine
interaktion bislang vor allem unter
ästhetischen gesichtspunkten
betrachtet also was kann ich dadurch
besser erkennen wie kann ich die welt
besser verstehen
ich kann nicht informationen besser
ordnen wie kann ich musste erkennen ich
glaube auch dass die
mensch-maschine-interaktion
redaktion ästhetische verstanden werden
kann das heißt es handelt sich dabei um
ästhetische inter objektivität
kunstschaffende und künstliche
intelligenz verhalten sich nicht wie
subjekt und objekt oder wie es subjekt
und instrument ich glaube dass ein
instrumentalist ischer zugriff auf
künstliche intelligenz im kontext von
ästhetik der digitalität zu kurz greift
dass das ein reduktionistischen
verständnis von künstlern intelligent
ist vielmehr bilden sie also
kunstschaffen der und künstliche
intelligenz einen interaktiven
kreativen zusammenhang im sinne
virtueller kunstproduktion künstliche
intelligenz wird zu einer virtuellen
mose zu einer virtuellen
inspirationsquelle durch die möglichkeit
der modifikation variation und
transformation bestehende kunst
künstliche intelligenz ist als solches
sicherlich nicht kreativ aber sie lässt
sich in kreative prozesse als ein moment
des kunstschaffens integrieren künstlich
in die gaskammer überraschungen und neue
perspektiven erzeugen die als
inspiration für unser kunstschaffen die
in köln in diesem sinne glaube ich
sollten wir kürzlich intelligenz in
ästhetischer hinsicht verstehen nicht im
sinne von robotern die plötzlich geniale
bilder malen das ist glaube ich wieder
zu sehr
personifizierte sehr antrieb
humoristisch glaube wir sollten die
mensch maschine interaktion im sinne
eines prozesses denken zudem kann er wie
auch menschliche künstlerinnen können
dazu gehören der nächsten zeit so wollen
wir uns noch mal mit der ästhetik der
digitalität befassen diesmal anhand des
phänomens der computerspiele die wie ich
glaube deswegen interessant sind weil
sie unser verständnis für virtuelle
realität besonders herausfordernd wie
geht es da und fiktion illusion realität
virtualität
simulation in ein besonderes
spezifisches verhältnis zu bringen
dieses verhältnis auch auszutesten an
die grenzen der realität zu gehen und
darin besteht nicht nur der ästhetisches
und auch die ethischen heitz von
computerspielen dann bedanke ich mich
vielmals für aufmerksamkeit und freue
mich auf die diskussion die gerne unten
dann im kommentarbereich erfolg